that day thousands of students and
parents went to Stoneman Douglas high
yesterday for the first time since the
shooting they're not scheduled to go
back to class until Wednesday people
marched on the sidewalk and dropped off
flowers at a memorial to honor the 17
who were killed
Omar Villafranca is at the school in
parkland Florida he talked to some of
the returning students and parents this
have been great so it's just very tough
to be here tough experience they've been
an inspiration to me I want to lock in
this sport my head held high because I
know that's what they would have wanted
it kind of feels strange that now it's
like a it's like a place I can't go in
it's like one of those buildings that
you pass by and you always wonder what
the story is behind it I am considering
not sending my kids back to school
unless I feel that this is a safe
environment for my children and the rest
of the children we're gonna hold each
other closer than we ever have before I
think out of all this something
beautiful is really coming out of it and
this whole community shows it this
school the kids there they're just
speaking out you know they can do a lot
they can they can change the law in this
country they can I believe they I
believe the kinder
they can make history here teachers are
returning to work today and tomorrow
there is a little ray of light here in
parkland thanks to the Stoneman Douglas
Club hockey team just last night they
want a state championship title and it
was nice to see that it comes at a
really good time I saw an interview it's
one of the students that said look two
weeks ago I was a busboy cleaning up
tables and washing dishes and now today
I'm being compared to one of the Freedom
Riders because they're pushing so hard
for change it's a very interesting